you guys you don't go to Disneyworld
that's what I liked about it because
your snobby [ __ ] yeah pieces of [ __ ]
like what do you guys do for a living
you're attacked or something yeah you
are now I really like the car the better
people they try to be the more evil
their jobs are that's all the way it is
here now this time probably works for
ten cops yes but when it does you
couldn't get a straight answer I can't
be like well you know you know it's an
experimental it's you know a
multi-platform you know you know we're
enhancing the user experience
it's a LinkedIn for human traffickers
what do you do for them what kind of
products that's not how the world works
I love you both you're both [ __ ] too
[ __ ] cool somewhat genderless modern
human day looks like you don't have a
gender you're so [ __ ] modern you
could little you be more for the same
person you probably sleep I'll upside
down like that collection you're [ __ ]
the bag and then you drink a bunch a lot
to every morning and it takes it back
that these people are coming to replace
you that's what's happening in America
right now the tech demons are coming to
replace the old racist banker